It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us for our 142nd episode!
BAU BAU!
We're back, Ruffians!
It's been a while!
BAU BAU!
We're so happy to be back finally!
Thank you, Ruffians!
For Ruffians maybe joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
I aim this to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's morning in your heart, right?
That's the important thing you know.
A new week?
Almost a new month too!
Oh my gosh.
We hope that we'll make it a wonderful April together with you, Ruffians!
I love FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Nihon wa shigatsu tsuitachi April furu!
Eh, mada!
Kokoro no naka wa mada.
BAU BAU is not April Fools yet!
No!
BAU BAU!
It's not... Yeah.
It's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
More eyes.
Moco-chan, you're not April Fools!
Not yet?
What do we have today?
Not April Fools, we have some bad news.
I thought that was right.
April Fool's!
Right, Moco-chan?
This is why you say April Fool's!
April Fool's!
No?
Ruffians!
What?
Why?
Why do we have to start off our FUWAMOCO Morning this way, Moco-chan?
It's important!
The Ruffians need to be informed of us, I guess.
Okay, well... Where was Pero spotted this time, Moco-chan?
Let's take a look.
The birds!
When I went on a walk today, the birds looked like they were having a nice bath.
There's a weird bird in there with them.
Yeah?
One of those birds is not a very... It's a nasty bird.
Well, uh, hopefully he's just there for a bath and nothing more, you know.
We haven't seen him eat a bird before.
But, I guess it could be possible.
We just haven't seen it, you know.
That is true.
Maybe he already ate one.
Poor Pero, no privacy.
I'm sure it won't go away.
He won't be any less nasty!
BAU BAU.
At least she's far away from us, huh?
I'm not gonna go take a bath in there with the birds.
Let's not do that okay, Ruffians?
No.
It looks cool anyway.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians!
We're back and we have some news, some things to share!
Let's step forward, Ruffians.
We missed you!
We're back!
We missed you so much!
FUWAMOCO's back!
FUWAMOCO Morning is back!
You know, it was an especially rough March.
You know, we had exciting things going on with FES and X-MON.
I happened to get super sick.
Yeah.
It was whatever was going around!
And, well, especially sick.
Yeah.
I had a bad fever and I couldn't speak or even make a sound.
It was really rough.
I was whispering everywhere.
It was really annoying.
Couldn't hear me, Moco-chan.
No!
But I'm still not 100% and I'm a little weak still, but I'm doing my best, so... You know, unfortunately we had a bunch of fun plans!
A bunch of fun streams!
Right after first.
We're gonna do this and that, you know!
But then things took a turn.
Right!
What was that?
Yeah.
But, uh, we didn't have a horror game festival, but Moco-chan at the very least, you were able to have your very first solo stream and you played Phasmophobia.
I tried!
Yeah, it was something else.
Something else!
Did you ever see the ghost?
I don't think she ever saw the ghost, right?
Door Simulator?
Yeah, the door was very scary apparently.
Yeah, I did my best.
It was a good stream, thank you!
Yeah, but, uh, well actually... We had to head back to the Moc Guy for some very important Demon Dog duties in the Northwest Passage.
So...
Yeah, that's what we've been kind of busy with, with the last little bit.
Yeah, it was rough because we are going right from sick to makai.
But we are still sick.
Yeah.
It is way too fun to get in with you Ruffians, but we did our best to push ourselves and get everything done while we were there.
And you know, we were able to see mama puppy and papa puppy a bit too, so...
Now we're back.
We're back.
There is still a bunch of homework to get done, but I'm looking forward to having some serious fun together with you Ruffians!
Thank you for waiting for us to return, Ruffians!
We missed you!
We have some more news!
Before we left, somehow, we're able to finally share a new song cover!
Here's some more!
It's a first cover song for a while, but this time it's quite different from the songs that we've sung up until now.
Ruffians!
What did you think of it?
It's a very small and emotional song, but this time it's in English!
English!
Yeah, not in Japanese.
That's a good cover!
Thank you!
Amazing!
BAU BAU!
You like that?
Your favorite!
I caught you tearing up!
It's too early for tears, Ruffians!
You like that it was in English this time?
You know, as you might know, because a lot of our senpai have talked about it, but it's actually very, very hard for hololive English members to do covers of songs in English!
But actually, Crescent Moon is originally a Japanese song with an official English translation.
So it's a bit different.
Originally...
It's a very famous J-pop song called Mikazuki by Ayaka.
And that's why we're able to sing it this time.
But it's really that hard.
It's official lyrics.
We still haven't been able to have an afterparty or talk about, you know, why we picked this song, what it means to us, you know, all the stuff about it.
So we hope that you'll join us for an afterparty!
We'll talk about it in the afterparty lots, okay?
Ruffians, it makes us really happy if you could continue listening to it lots and lots!
We'll also talk about it in the afterparty.
You know, our time away in the Northwest Pass is killing us.
But thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you for listening to it lots and lots while we are away.
If you haven't listened to it yet, please go take a listen!
Go check it out!
Maybe that's your theme song for this morning after FUWAMOCO Morning.
It's not quite the right time, but it's okay.
BAU BAU!
You listen to it again later?
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
I'm always happy to release new songs.
I want to sing lots and lots.
Hopefully there will be more in the future too.
Ruffians, while we were away, there was actually a very important announcement made from a beloved senpai of hololive English Promise.
Wow, Nanashi Momoe.
She announced that she will be graduating on April 27th.
Yeah.
We're really, really sad to know that we'll be having to say goodbye so soon.
I'm sure you know, but she's just been such a sweet and lovely senpai and such an amazing singing voice.
We're really gonna miss her.
Yeah.
She has such a great energy.
Why?
But...
We had a lot of fun playing Overwatch 2 and we got to hang out a bunch during fests.
But it's hard when you think you know that those times are limited now.
It's funny because I feel like we spent a lot more time chatting and hanging out.
Maybe I want to stream!
Yeah, you know we did this together in the movies and that and you know all the magic.
Dinner date.
All right!
You know.
We thought together.
Thanks a lot, Abyss!
And we chatted about this.
Yes, you know.
Yeah.
But we can only hope that you know, we'll have lots and lots of fun together before that day, you know.
Yeah, so.
But we'll miss moving some pylons, not so.
Yeah.
Thank you FUWAMOCO for everything!
It was a lot of fun!
We still have a month together!
Yes!
Be silly!
Bye bye!
It's lonely, right?
Make every moment count!
Let's all do that every single day, okay?
BAU BAU!
Also from hololive English Bonus!
The Warden of Time, Kurenai-senpai!
She revealed a brand new outfit as part of her birthday celebration!
Look at that silhouette!
It looks pretty cute there!
That we're very interested in.
Maid cronies!
Yes!
Give me my new outfit and... Oh my gosh!
It's so cute!
So cute, BAU BAU!
Oh my gosh, how can my cronies have Barbie this cute?
But, I can't.
Look, look, you know... There's so many different types of maids and maid outfits, but you know, I...
A type of meat that strikes us the most deeply.
Inside of our hearts.
Is this one right here?
Yeah, you know.
Victoria-style meat that goes down to the ankles.
You know it's very high quality, lean, simple, black and white.
And she made it for us.
She made it for us!
It's for us!
You know it.
Ready, baby!
What?
Huh?
Nobody.
No.
You know her.
Look, you know her.
She can't even hide behind her hair!
Bridge!
The last bridge that go down near the... I thought, I thought... They're a little bit messy, but that's because she's been working so hard around the mansion.
I wanted bridge.
When I saw the silhouette, I thought I wanted bridge, but she can't have bridge.
That's too much for me.
FUWAMOCO have a mansion?
I have a mansion inside my delusions!
I want to do so much FUWAMOCO Morning!
I want to run underneath her skirt there and put the legs.
I want to get in the way of all the cleaning.
I want to sleep in the sun on her lap.
Maybe play with the little pumpkin watch that's here.
I want to pull on the sides of the dress and be like, this way, this way!
I want to rip off the couch!
Look at the strings there, Moco-chan!
I'm just going to take it right away and then hide it.
Right, right.
You'll hide it behind the rose bush.
That's the perfect place for Moco-chan.
Exactly!
It's so cute.
The only thing left is glasses.
But we can just imagine though.
You know, if we had glasses, I think, you know, it's probably for the best because otherwise we'd be dead, right Moco-chan?
That's so good of a general feeling.
I have no words!
If anybody wants to, you know, maybe draw,
FUWAMOCO and me cronies are adventurers.
There's ideas.
Lots of ideas.
More ideas.
Can definitely share with you.
BAU BAU!
Now, I'm maybe not so happy.
We have Ruffians!
We saw on Twitter that there's a very controversial graph going around.
Let's take a look.
Whoa!
Apparently, this is a graph of a whole young member's land depending on height to gain more energy.
How do height and gain more energy rhyme?
Why is it more complex?
I don't know why height.
Gain more energy.
You see this, Ruffians?
I have a question.
What's the question?
Why are we all on the side away from the camera?
Why?
Huh?
What is gamer energy?
It's not gamer skills.
Yeah.
It's energy!
Huh?
Don't we have lots of that?
Ruffians, lots of love, lots of energy for gamers!
We're retro gamers, you know it!
Retro gamers, that's FUWAMOCO!
It's not about skills, it's about energy.
Yeah.
You see my FPS gamer energy, right?
You see that, right?
If that's not gamer energy, I don't know what that is.
Right?
Obviously, this chart is very wrong.
Right, Ruffians?
You agree, right?
You have lots of love for games.
Maybe not skills, but... Energy!
Energy!
Yes, it's super wrong, yes.
Yeah.
Yeah!
You agree?
Well we have more proof of what's wrong!
We have proof!
Actual evidence!
Yes!
Because!
Wow!
FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be guests at Holo Gamers Fest!
At Saitama Super Arena 2!
Gamers 2!
Gamers is gonna be doing a big gaming event!
FUWAMOCO will be there on day 2!
Along with Subaru-senpai and Mikocchi-senpai.
Fuwamiko!
Fuwamiko and Fuwamiko!
We're gonna play games all together!
FUWAMOCO
It's super!
It's a super arena!
I think it's the third largest arena in the world?
Something crazy like that?
It's big!
Very big!
Yeah yeah yeah!
Way way big!
So we're gonna play games then!
And there's not only streaming tickets for the event as well, but there's also in-person tickets!
So Ruffians excited that they got their tickets!
But you know, if you haven't yet, please apply for the lottery!
Please get them!
Streaming tickets will be available, so please check it out!
Don't miss it!
It's gonna be very silly and chaotic for sure!
I have a feeling, yeah.
FUWAMOCO has gamer energy.
No misunderstandings.
No.
It's not even a misunderstanding yet.
It's clear.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
You know, it's a new week.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
And that means there's gotta be a Doggie of the Day, right?
Wow.
Let's take a look at today's Doggie of the Day.
Today's Doggie of the Day is...
De-den!
It's Pelusa!
BAU BAU!
It's time!
Right!
Pelusa's a new puppy!
New family member!
New family!
But apparently Pelusa means fluffy or fuzzy in Spanish.
Pelusa!
Melissa!
Look at those ears to the tail!
I feel like the paws are so big!
Apparently, despite her tiny size, she has a big attitude.
Yeah, very cute.
I can see it in the eyes there.
The stance as well.
Power stance.
Moco-chan, how does Melissa bow-bow?
Bow-bow!
Bye bye!
Huh?
You think it's so rough?
It's so silly.
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO is still just the size of a little boy, but she has attitude!
She has presence!
It's important, yes!
Yeah, and you know her!
She'll be an even bigger silly when she becomes a full-grown doggy too!
Please give her lots of high fives and cheats for us, okay?
BAU BAU!
And Ruffians, you have to make sure to keep those paws out going for walks, right?
Right, and no sprinkles here!
It's purple!
Wow, let's take a look at where this Ruffian went on a walk.
Today I went on a walk.
Have a day!
Daffodils!
I love daffodils!
These are Moco-chan.
I think these are yellow narcissus.
Is this not daffodils?
I thought these were always daffodils.
I thought they were daffodils.
Moco-chan daffodils.
Daffodils!
Maybe it's like a bouncier daffodil.
Wow, idling is super pretty!
It feels like spring 100%!
100%.
1000%!
Look at the eggs down there.
Natural.
Natural?
That's what you see in nature.
At the bottom of flowers, there's always eggs.
Oh, yeah.
You know, especially FUWAMOCO egg plushies.
Ah, love it!
Excited to be booming with you.
Did you just say excited, Moco-chan?
Stop.
Thank you for taking us on your springtime walk!
BAU BAU!
No more, Moco-chan!
No more!
I didn't say anything.
BAU BAU!
After our Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
When did you first notice you were feeling unwell?
Did you both get sick at the same time, or did one of you fall ill first?
Get well soon!
BAU BAU!
I think this time, it was...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Yeah.
But you know, by the end of the day we had a very fun day.
I was feeling very rough.
Yeah.
And actually we had even more plans for fun later.
But they got cancelled because all of us were really sick.
We were not feeling well!
But let's cancel our plans.
But you know... I'd totally be able to get to see everybody more!
Yeah!
But I don't think that was the last time then, huh?
I know FUWAMOCO!
Generally when it comes to sickness...
If one of us is not feeling great, the other one is, you know.
Yeah, not feeling great either.
You know, even things for like headaches and stuff too.
Yeah.
It makes sense.
Yeah, this time is a little bit rare because Moco-chan, you're doing much better than me.
Not great, but still, I was not doing well.
But I'm glad to be doing much, much better now.
Mostly better now, but I'm still gonna make sure to take it easy, Ruffians.
Please forgive me if I sound stumped up.
Maybe I have to mute off, you know?
Sounds like a dog.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for all your submissions, FUWAMOCO!
Thank you!
Please remember, FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make together!
The morning together with you!
So we're always looking for more submissions.
Don't need these.
Doesn't need to have to be your doggy.
Just send it with the hashtag.
I saw this dog.
Yeah, you know.
Maybe it's best to ask for it, Fuwara.
But you know, also lots of springtime things going on.
Good opportunity for some nice walks.
Also, Ruffians, I know you have questions.
It's been quite a while since we did a Q&A, so please send us your questions.
And also, it is too, let us know what you thought.
Please use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
What do we have for our next stream?
What do we?
We haven't released a schedule or anything.
Ruffians, maybe you'd like to take a look at a little bit of a schedule.
Let's take a look!
De-den!
Our next stream is gonna be tomorrow!
We're having an advent collab.
Question mark.
You have to join us, Ruffians!
Ignore the fact that it's on the 1st, okay?
And on this day we have another FUWAMOCO Morning followed by finally a Crescent Moon song cover release after party!
We wanted to chat about it and chat about you know our time in the Northwest Passage a little bit too so please join us for just you know some nice chatting.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
And on Friday, we have another FUWAMOCO Morning with you, Ruffians!
Followed by some Donkey Kong Country tunes!
It's been a while!
Speaking of been a while... Little Witch Nobita is back, Ruffians!
Remember?
Ruffians, do you remember when we were in Nobita?
Do you?
Do you remember?
Do you remember we played that game before?
Probably a long time ago.
Right!
We started it back when we just debuted!
Yeah!
Are we gonna finish it this time, Moco-chan?
Do you remember it?
Wow!
That's good!
Because we'll have a summary!
We'll be able to fill the Ruffians in!
Because...
We don't have our data.
So Moco-chan's job now.
You're gonna do your best to re-learn where we were with the story of the game.
And then we'll be starting back off where we were.
I don't know where my data is!
Why?
But it'll be okay because Moco-chan, you couldn't be getting so caught up.
I couldn't be a gamer, okay?
Yes.
I was thinking of getting back to where I was.
Off stream.
That's the plan.
And then, hopefully Ruffians will be able to beat Nobeta!
All together on Saturday.
And then on Sunday we'll be having a Question Question Question Mic Off Club.
Question Question Question Mic Channel!
We're looking forward to it.
It's very early in the morning so maybe Ruffians, instead of hoarding your sleep schedule, maybe you can join us in the archive for that one.
But if you happen to be awake, please join us!
And then on Sunday we'll be doing a super chat reading.
And just chatting about a bunch of different things that's been on our minds.
You know, and hearing how things have been for you too, Ruffians!
You know, maybe you're back from your trip to Japan, or maybe you went on another trip!
Let us know how things have been going for you, you know?
We miss you!
So take a little bit of a moment to slow down a little bit and just have a nice time together.
And that's our schedule for this week.
BAU BAU!
I'm so excited to be able to, you know, have some fun together with Advent very soon.
It'll be nice being able to play some games too, together!
Thank you, Ruffians!
And for Ruffians joining us in the archive today, we have your FUWAMOCO word for you!
It's...
BAU BAU!
We miss you!
Thank you!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Rufficron!
BAU BAU!
Fingon!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Good morning!